hello guys and welcome back to
jaegerists
in today's video we will be going
through the story of bertholt
hoover leave a like on this video and
subscribe to our channel if you want to
see more content like this
berthold was an aldean born in the
continent of marley
at some point in his childhood he joined
the marlian military as a warrior
candidate
he was praised for his shooting
abilities and was selected along with
annie leonhardt
and marcel galliard to become warriors
and candidates to inherit the power of
the titans
bertholdt one day noticed a fellow
candidate named porco galliard
bullying reiner braun a smaller
candidate after porco left
bertholdt helped reiner to his feet and
formed a lifelong friendship with him
upon acquiring the power of the colossus
titan he learned to use its power almost
immediately
he along with reiner annie and marcel
began a mission to attack the wild
aldians in the year 845.
the main objective of the mission was to
steal the power of the founding titan
and bring it to the marley government
the day they were about to breach
wall maria the warriors encountered
yamir's titan while traveling
still in a mindless state she attacked
the three boys and nearly killed reiner
marcel ended up sacrificing his life to
protect his friends
they later regrouped and were about to
abandon the mission but reiner stopped
them
reminding them of the consequence annie
enraged and terrified
attacked reiner wilst bertholdt could
only watch the scuffle
after reiner took the lead and decided
that they would continue the mission the
remaining warriors headed to the wall
and began their operation
bertholdt transforms into his colossus
titan form at shiganshinan district
terrorizing its population and kicking a
hole in the district's gate
the attack leads to falling debris
scattering across the town crushing
houses in the process
immediately after his attack bertholdt
reverts to his human self
while titans enter the city from outside
the walls resulting in the population
being set on by them
after exiting his titan berthwalk comes
in close proximity with a pure
titan but is ignored as it instead
entered shiganshinan district
after the armored titan breaches while
maria beritholt manages to enter along
with reiner braun and annie leonhart
during the abandonment of the wall
bertholdt and the other two forged their
family records
berthold and reiner find work as
lumberjacks for two years whilst annie
gathers information inside walshina
together they masquerade as refugees
from deep in the mountains south of
walmaria
who learned of the attack at dawn as
their village was under assault by
titans a tale stolen from a deceased
colleague
the trio later discussed their discovery
that king fritz and the nobles are
puppet rulers and not
actual subjects of ymir they then decide
to enlist his soldiers so that they can
join the military police and get close
to the interior
eventually berthold enlists in the
military academy as part of the 104th
training corps
with aspirations of joining the military
police brigade and living in the safety
of the inner wall
he was considered to be one of the best
in regards to vertical maneuvering
equipment
enough so that aaron jaeger came to him
for advice when he was dealing with
faulty equipment
after seeing aaron's determination and
desire to join the survey corps
he considered himself a coward for
wanting to get far away from them
however
aaron encouraged him saying that after
witnessing the attack on his village
no one would blame him for his decision
eventually
he graduated in the top 10 of his class
coming in at third place
just under his friend reiner braun five
years after his attack on shiganshinon
district bertholdt transforms into the
colossus titan
at the entrance of the tross district he
immediately repels the military trainees
on top of wall rose with vapor from his
high temperature body
and then breaches the gate into the city
he takes note of aaron yeager preparing
to attack
but disregards him for the time being as
he sets his eyes on the wall's fixed
artillery
the colossus titan swings his arm and
destroys the wall's defenses
surviving the assault aaron launches
himself at the colossus titan's neck and
attempts to attack his nape
leading to berthold dissolving his
titan's body and aaron missing his
target
his attack prompts the garrison to begin
the colossus titan contingency plan for
trost district
and results in titans entering the city
upon re-entering trust
bertholdt takes part in the attack
against the titans however
with the supply team stuck in tross
military headquarters
he is essentially immobilized with many
of his teammates on a rooftop
he reiner braun and annie leonhart
discuss what to do next with reiner
suggesting that they wait for the titans
to gather to them before they make a
move
mikasa ackerman asked them if they have
seen aaron and reiner points out armin
alert
telling her he was in aaron's squad
mikasa takes charge
leading an attempt to get to the
military headquarters and trust which
berthold takes part in
connie springer mikasa and armin arrive
shortly afterward
with an abnormal titan in tow that
promptly begins killing the titans
swarming the outside of the building
bertholdt takes part in armin's plan to
clear out the smaller titans that have
infiltrated the headquarters armory
after the titans are lured together by
the cadets and blinded via gunfire
he and six other cadets attack them in
an effort to clear out all of the titans
in one move
as the other cadets move out after
resupplying berthold is among the
soldiers that stay behind to observe the
abnormal titan as it is overwhelmed by
the mindless titans
suspecting that the titan is intelligent
bertholdt annie and reiner argue that
they should help it and prevent it from
being eaten
they are silenced when the titan breaks
away from the titans devouring it to
kill one final titan before collapsing
they prepare to leave but are shocked at
the sight of aaron emerging from the
titan's nape
bertholdt gene kirsten annie and reiner
are placed on standby with their fellow
cadets and are ordered not to tell
anyone what they witnessed
after seeing what appears to be titan
vapor from inside the city
he and the soldiers that witnessed
aaron's emergence from the titan's nape
scale the wall to see what is happening
they see aaron protecting mikasa and
armin from cannon fire
with a shield made from the torso of his
titan form
soon after aaron transforms into the
attack titan to seal the breach and
trust
and bertholdt discusses the events with
reiner as their plan is foiled
their conversation is overheard by marco
bott leading to reiner immobilizing him
while annie removes his vertical
maneuvering equipment as the three
abandoned marco bertholdt looks on in
shock as he is
partially eaten by a titan after the
ordeal bertholdt joins the survey corps
with reiner braun alongside mikasa
ackerman
aaron yeager connie springer and a few
others
instead of following the warriors
original plan to join the military
police brigade alongside annie leonhardt
bertholdt participates in the survey
corps 57th expedition outside the walls
the mission is fairly slow paced for him
until he arrives at the titan forest
with his group
and is ordered to be on standby he waits
atop the trees with his comrades so that
they may stop any titan from entering
the forest where their superiors are
a loud titan scream can be heard from
within the forest and several titans
begin to charge in
after the titans are gone beyond the
soldier's watchpoint bertholdt sees the
smoke signal indicating the time for
retreat
he regroups with his comrades and they
head back to the walls upon re-entering
the gate
the survey corps receives comments and
criticisms for their loss of life and
lack of results
in the aftermath of a failed mission to
capture the female titan
berethold is among the recruits placed
under observation at an old mansion
and suspected of being a potential
accomplice of annie leonhart
when titans are discovered within wall
rose he is one of the soldiers placed on
the squad
sent to evacuate villages in the south
that evening the southern squad meets up
with amir and christus squad
and they decide to take refuge for the
night in utgard castle at some point
during the night
the castle comes under attack by titans
and the recruits are forced to defend
the interior from the smaller titans
that have invaded
after reiner braun takes off on his own
to investigate bertholdt offers a
strange observation of his friend's bad
habit of risking himself for others
when a titan manages to break through a
stairwell door he comes to rhino's
defense with a pitchfork and helps fight
it off
the two reaffirm their promise to
survive and return to their home
together
after a second titan manages to enter
and injure reiner he helps emir toss it
out of a window
he begins to behave in a withdrawn
manner commenting that reiner has
changed and is no longer a
warrior however he refuses to elaborate
further on the subject
eventually their superiors are killed by
the attacking titans and the rookies are
left defenseless
this drives amir to reveal herself to be
a titan using her powers to protect the
others
bertholdt along with reiner are shocked
to recognize her as the titan that had
killed their friend marcel galliard
several years earlier the group is
eventually rescued by haines zoe's squad
and evacuate to the wall with the
intention of regrouping with their main
forces
injured and distressed over their ordeal
reiner breaks down under the stress and
confesses their identities to aaron
yeager
while berthold watches in growing
distress when aaron tries to tell reiner
that he is just
tired and making things up bertholdt
agrees but reiner then confirms their
identities by tearing off his bandage
and showing his injured arm is rapidly
healing
bertholdt shocked by his actions asks if
they are really going to reveal
themselves now
however the two of them are viciously
attacked by mikasa ackermann before they
are able to transform
critically wounded and terrified
bertholdt transforms into a partial
titan form
and begins to attack the soldiers on the
wall while reiner attempts to kidnap
aaron
in the chaos he manages to capture amir
and a random soldier
swallowing them both whole afterward he
counters an attack by hange's squad
through generating intense heat and
steam
burning anyone that gets too close he
remains in a skeleton-like state
burning profusely to prevent any attack
against him directly below
the armored titan is overpowered by
aaron's titan and begins roaring
in response the colossus titan topples
from the wall and lands on top of a
fighting aaron and reiner
exploding upon impact the resulting
explosion wounds most of the survey
corps soldiers
and allows reiner and bertholdt to
successfully capture aaron and flee the
scene
several hours later he takes refuge with
reiner and their two captives in the
titan forest
he is mostly silent during the following
arguments and discussions
only speaking up when prompted by amir
or aaron bertholdt is greatly distressed
by reiner's strange behavior
and is shown to have known about it long
before anyone else he is able to bring
his friend back to reality
by reminding him that he is not a
soldier but rather that they are both
warriors aaron later confronts him about
his role in the death of carlo yeager
demanding to know what he thought when
he learned about the suffering he would
cause
he responds with a vague comment about
having felt sorry for him
horrifying aaron and leading him to
scream at them both though amir agrees
to work with them when offered bertholdt
remains unconvinced and warns reiner
that she cannot be trusted he brings up
the death of their friend who was
devoured by amir though reiner reassures
him that she can be trusted since her
only consideration is krista's safety
but is reminded that krista has
value to them since she is a member of
the reese family and may be able to
provide them with important clues
reina responds by teasing him demanding
that he confess his feelings to annie
once they make it home
berthold attempts to protest but reiner
claims his tendency to stare at her gave
him away
the pair notice a signal flare and
realize the rescue team has already
found them and prepared to flee
while reiner subdues aaron bertholdt
confronts mir over the death of his
friend
she states she has no memory of having
done it but apologizes to him and
asks if he hates her he admits that he
is not certain
but he cannot hold her responsible since
none of them wanted to devour humans
he asks how long she wandered as a pure
titan and implies that he and rainer may
also have spent some time trapped in
their titan forms in the past
as the group flees ymir notices the
signal flares and becomes agitated
she demands that they kidnap krista and
attacks berthold when they refuse
they are forced to land in the trees and
she further physically intimidates and
threatens bertholdt until they relent
when samir returns from kidnapping
krista
he straps an unconscious air into his
back and both cling to the armored
titan's back as he runs from the
pursuing troops
realizing how close the troops have
already gotten he shouts at amir for
having delayed them too much
he demands to know what they have been
doing all this for and whether she
intends to abandon krista inside the
walls to save herself
a short time later mikasa manages to get
onto the armored titan's back
and attacks him here before turning on
bertholdt to escape
he slips down onto the front of reiner's
neck and shouts for him to protect them
in response reiner cups his hands around
his neck and encloses berthold and
aaron safely against his neck aaron now
awake
begins to struggle and ignores all
efforts to calm him down the other
members of the 104th training corps
climb onto the armored titan's shoulders
and begin to shout at bertholdt in his
hiding place he initially attempts to
ignore them
ajin kirsten and connie springer
alternately attempt to coax him out and
confront him over his betrayal
at last he breaks into tears and yells
at them that he never wanted to kill
anyone
he confesses to having truly thought of
the 104th as his friends
stating that their time together was
very enjoyable even so
he refuses to surrender and return aaron
stating that
someone has to do it before he can
elaborate any further
hanes screams a warning to the group as
erwin smith
leads a horde of titans directly towards
them this forces them to retreat for a
time while reiner attempts to charge
through the oncoming horde in his titan
form
it ultimately proves hopeless and the
armored titan is quickly overwhelmed by
the large group and forced to begin
using his hands to fight
no longer protected by his partner
bertholdt is forced to defend himself
when the soldiers return in force and
attack him
beginning to panic he shouts to reiner
that they have to bring aaron back to
their home
he narrowly escapes another attack by
mikasa and is confronted by armand alert
who reveals that annie has been captured
taunting bertholdt
he asks if they intend to abandon their
comrade and claims that annie is
currently being tortured by the military
for information
with great care being taken to ensure
that she does not die
this drives berthold into a rage and
distracts him long enough for a wounded
airwin to launch a surprise attack and
free eren
bertholdt can only watch in shock as the
soldiers begin their retreat
he remains perched on the armored
titan's shoulder as it begins to hurl
titans at the fleeing soldiers
slowly healing his injuries when aaron's
power as the coordinate activates
he senses it and reacts with shock the
partners begin to pursue aaron once
freed from the titan horde attacking
them
but this freedom is short-lived taking
advantage of his newfound power
aaron screams at them to stay away and
threatens to kill them
both react with shock and horror sensing
aaron's power and realizing that it has
directed the horde at them once again
reiner initially attempts to protect him
from attackers
but they are quickly overwhelmed and he
is forced to fight on his own
his screams draw amir's attention
causing her to hesitate in fleeing with
the soldiers
just as a titan is about to kill him
emir appears and rescues him
the three titans begin to fight together
while the human soldiers retreat back to
the walls
the group exhausted from their two-day
ordeal
rest atop walmaria while attempting to
make sense of things
he questions amir about her decision to
save his life
and is shocked that her actions were
motivated by gratitude for having been
saved from her eternal nightmare
knowing that she faces an uncertain
future when they return with her to
their hometown
bertholdt struggles to hold back his
tears while thanking her around the time
the survey court departs for their
operation to retake walmaria
bertholdt and reiner braun sit atop the
wall amongst a small campsite they made
the two watch the sunset as they await
the arrival of their enemy and prepare
to begin their own operation
zeke assures them that annie leonhart is
not being tortured
reiner and berthorth are still doubtful
and regardless annie's identity was
still revealed
zeke then questions whether the two of
them are fully committed reminding them
of the deal they made in the past and
questioning if he had gone through all
that trouble for nothing
he tells reiner that they can fight
again if he wishes but if they do and
reiner loses he will have to give up his
armor to another warrior
when reiner backs down zeke tells him to
pull himself together so they can focus
on their goal of recovering the
coordinate
and putting an end to this cursed
history bertholdt agrees to put thoughts
of annie aside for now
claiming that no one else has to go
through hell except for them remembering
the pain of annie
marcobot and reiner bertholdt expresses
a desire to end
all the fighting pj finger in her titan
form
appears below and alerts them of the
core's imminent arrival
and the three warriors share a last
toast before preparing for battle
as bertholdt and reiner jog along
walmaria reiner notes that the two of
them will be in separate positions
and that bertholdt will have to think
and act for himself rather than wait for
reiner's signal
reiner admits that he never thought of
bertholt as particularly reliable before
as he tends to leave things to others
when it matters in spite of his immense
ability
but not anymore the earththought affirms
his desire to end things
the two-part ways when the survey corps
makes it to the shiganshinan district
they begin rushing the gate with 100
soldiers to confuse the enemy
as aaron yeager flies up above the
breach in walmaria's southern gate
he prepares to transform just as this is
happening
he watches from an unknown location
equipped with his vertical maneuvering
equipment as berthold stands by
he wonders about the outcome of the
surprise attack and when reiner will
give out the signal
soon after reiner lets out a roar
singling berthold to be thrown in a
barrel towards his position by zeke
upon hearing the armored titans roar the
beast titan throws the barrel with
berthold inside towards reiner's
position
bethel prepares to transform but upon
seeing reiner's damage titan form
he abandons the plan and rushes over to
check on his friend
he discovers that while reiner survived
the thunderspheres he was forced to
transfer his consciousness to his titan
body
he tells reiner that he will need to
move a little and if he cannot
then he will have to prepare for the
worst berthold declares that he is
ending this and heads towards the
soldiers as he approaches
armin alert calls out to him and asks to
negotiate berthold gives him the
warrior's conditions
aaron and the demise of humanity within
the walls he calls this the harsh truth
of reality
and claims it has already been decided
when armin asks who decided this
rutheld admits that he did armin tries
to bait him by tearing berthold about
annie's supposed torture again
but bertholdt no longer falls for it and
expresses doubt the military police even
has her
when armin tries to leave berthold cuts
him off taunting him about wanting to
talk
he asks if armin thought talking about
annie would upset him
because bertholt is supposed to be meek
and timid berthold knows that armin's
negotiation
is actually just buying time for the
soldiers to surround him and finish off
reiner he only agreed to talk to armin
because he wanted to see if he would
break down and ask for forgiveness
like the last time he was faced with his
former comrades but he no longer feels
conflicted about what he must do
and tells armin that even though the
soldiers are his cherished comrades
he still intends to kill them all
without warning mikasa ackerman appears
behind berthold and tries to go for the
killing blow
but berthold quickly blocks her blade
despite losing an ear
berthold manages to escape using his
vertical maneuvering gear
he maneuvers high into the sky noting
that he barely feels any fear
and thinks to himself that no matter how
things turn out he will be able to
accept the outcome
as nobody is truly in the wrong the
world is just simply cruel
he transforms and the resulting blast
engulfs all of the nearby soldiers
except for levi's squad and levels the
central portion of shiganshinon
the colossus titan then starts to pick
up buildings damaged from the blast and
throws them
all over the district many of them have
burst into flames due to the heat from
his titan
spreading the fire to the rest of the
district he then heads north towards
commander irwin smith's position
but is intercepted by aaron and the
104th recruits
aaron charges at bertholdt's leg
attempting to stop him in his tracks
with little effort berthold lifts the
leg with aaron's titan dangling from it
before sending aaron crashing into the
top of walmaria with a swift kick
the group charged at him to create a
diversion for mikasa to launch the
thunder spirit as nape
he emits a searing hot gas which forces
mikasa to retreat and injures connie
springer in the process
after the group has sought temporary
safety he continues to destroy the
district
as reiner recovers and begins to fight
the levi's squad herital notes that he
was hoping to kill everyone with his
transformation but calmly shrugs it off
saying he is used to such trials he
approaches aaron and armin
wondering what armin will do seconds
later aaron loses his balance and falls
to the ground
motionless bertholt thinking aaron is
already beaten decides to blow armin
away
and unleashes a burst of steam from his
body however much to his surprise
armin latches onto his teeth and refuses
to let go he questions what armin could
possibly hope to achieve with aaron
already beaten
but decides to finish him quickly and
launches one final burst charring
armin's skin
and burning his hair off sending him
falling lifelessly to the rooftops below
after observing armin's burnt body
bertholdt moves over to aaron's titan
body
only to find it a hardened shell he then
realizes too late that armin was buying
air in time to get out of his titan form
and use berthold's attack as a
smokescreen at that moment
aaron in his human form appears from
behind latching onto the colossus
titan's nape and slicing it open
severing berthold's arms and legs before
ripping him out and dragging him down to
the roof below
where a ravaged yet alive armin is lying
after being defeated and dragged out of
his colossus titan
berthold is approached by zeke and his
titan mount anticipating capture
aaron begins to slip berthold's throat
but zeke tells berthold that he cannot
save him this time
when levi pursues zeke aaron urges him
to give armor the titan injection so
that berthold can be fed to armin to
turn him into a titan and save him from
death
however another soldier arrives with
aarwin who is unconscious but also alive
the soldiers debate who should be given
the titan serum between erwin or armin
as berthold lies unconscious and at
their mercy
after a fair bit of debating levi is
left with the decision and finally
decides on who to give the serum to
bertholdt awakes to find himself at the
complete mercy of the armin's pure titan
he screams
begging his former allies to save him as
they watch tears in their eyes
bethel cries out for annie and reiner
before he is eaten alive by armin
armin has a nightmare about berthold
before he wakes up
he dreams that the colossus titan is
crying he is told by aaron that he ate
bertholdt in order to stay alive
which armin is mortified to learn during
the fight between the survey corps and
the titans of emir fritz
beretholt and a handful of other
inheritors are reawakened in the path
world by
zeke earthol approaches armin who
acknowledges that he stole bertholdt's
life
and titan before asking if bearthroat
will still lend him his strength
taking control of his titan bertholdt
immediately begins defending annie from
the hordes of titans which had been
overtaking her
he continues fending off the myriad
titans which are attempting to defend
aaron long enough for aaron's nape to be
destroyed
he then picks up armin with some of the
other titans and holds him as he
transforms into his colossus titan to
destroy the rest of aaron's titan
thank you guys so much for watching this
video it really means a lot to us
we will see you guys very soon in one of
our next videos